[Music]
simone is going to start off this hour
in buffalo new york hi simone how are
you
thank you so much for having me today
sure what's up so basically i'm really
blessed and i'm a new college i'm going
to graduate college in may of 2022 um
and i'm kind of blessed to be making a
hundred thousand dollars after
graduation with a ten thousand dollar
signing bonus so i kind of had two
weeks
what's your degree in
computer science way to go kiddo you
killed it yes
a college student with an actual career
i love it
yeah
um
so i guess one thing how do i like
properly make sure i use this amazing
salary to set myself up for the future
and um secondly how do i convince my
parents that i shouldn't take out a loan
for a car because i kind of wanted to
drive like a cheaper car that's like ten
thousand dollars using a sign-on bonus
but they kind of want me to take out
like a
massive car loan to get like a nice 30
000 car or something like that
okay um
i think you've reached a point kind of a
gone over the edge of the cliff now
in that you graduated you're 22 years
old you make a hundred thousand dollars
a year
uh you don't have to convince your
parents of anything honey
you're like an adult and stuff
i guess you're right
did what
i guess you're right i never really
thought about it that way yeah you don't
you don't need their permission no
it's your life
your money by the way too
so i mean just you know just smile and
say
mom and dad this is what i decided to do
and
thanks for your input
and by the way i may not go to the same
church you go to and
by the way i might buy a dress that's a
different color than one that you like
because i'm like an adult and stuff you
know i say that to them but that goes
through your mind right
yeah yeah this is the part where they
start to understand that having grown
children who are grown is the hardest
stage of parenting because you don't get
to tell them what to do anymore
no that makes sense because like they
like they wanted me to like kind of do
the whole i guess stay-at-home mom thing
and stuff and um
like kind of be like an english major
who like doesn't make a lot of money
and you decide to go like be a computer
genius and stuff
you're amazing so i mean listen i don't
want you to be unkind to your mom and
dad but the the point is you have
reached the point in your life where you
no longer have to have their permission
to do
anything
it would be nice to have their approval
but sometimes they may choose to
withhold that approval
okay i mean let me just tell you how bad
it gets sometimes like rachel ordered a
tesla
this is how bad it is
and i can't do anything about it
now you need to explain to the audience
why that bothers you so much i can't
stand those cars they're not real cars
they're a battery with four wheels dave
likes to smell
i want a loud muffler i'm a redneck and
i don't know how i possibly raised a
daughter that wants a battery but she
did so that's great
it's a big joke around our house so
the point i mean and if rachel were
sitting here she would love this
discussion too so but the point is is
that she did not buy the car to get her
father's approval otherwise she would
have bought a four-wheel drive truck
with loud mufflers so um
but you see what i'm saying so you you
know
and i love her and it's fine if she gets
a tesla i don't give a crap george
bought one too i mean i don't care
everybody's got one so i don't i don't
well i know ken because you're like a
real man and stuff
but the uh
even i laughed at that one
uh dave i want to say something real
quick here because i simone here's
here's something and dave i want you to
weigh in on this i think this is a
situation where
like a lot of the advice we give on
money it's like make the decision now
like don't wait and then you overthink
because what happens is the the the sway
that parents have over their children is
tremendous and rightfully so and i don't
want her to wait to tell mom and dad hey
listen i'm going to buy a ten thousand
dollar car i want her to just do it and
then she informs him later by the car
yes
yeah and pay cash for whatever you buy
yeah and then move up in car later
you're making a hundred thousand you
don't have to drive a ten thousand
dollar car
you can get a better car with cash later
as you go along and we're gonna give you
a graduation present i want you to go
through financial peace university is my
gift so we'll teach you how to handle
money you ask another question in the
call of what is the best process the
best process is to stay away from debt
it sounds like you have
get out of debt stay away from debt have
an emergency fund and begin to invest
long term
in your retirement account honey if you
are very careful if you're reasonably
wise you're going to be unbelievably
wealthy
um but if you go spend 110 000 while you
make 100 like you're in congress or
something then um
you know you're going to have all kinds
of issues and lots of people do that so
no i don't want you to have a car
payment
and uh if i were in your shoes if i woke
up in your shoes i would not advise you
to buy a brand new car
and i would advise you to be kind to
your mom and dad and
grateful to them for what they've done
for you and all those kinds of things
but they no longer
have
a
vote
that's how it works
and um you know
if you need their advice on something
you can ask their advice and they can
give advice but they don't
have to be convinced for you to do
anything you do and you can sense that
she
knew that they weren't right yeah and
she's kind of going how do i this was a
respect question she's a respectful
young lady it shows the power that
parents have and dave i just wonder at
what point culturally you know did it
become a thing where you got it's a
reasonable decision to take out a loan
for the dependability
of a new car
1967.
i made that up but somewhere around
there yeah i was curious car payments
became a thing in the six that's what i
was wondering when that became a
normality in the 50s and 40s there were
no car payments henry ford detested debt
huh he hated debt i did not know that if
he understood that ford motor company
made more money on
than ford does afford more to credit
makes more money than ford does he would
have been just
spinning in his grave you know i mean uh
and so you know that generation j.c
penney
was nicknamed james cash penny
he was tight he hated debt
and their credit cards on the jcpenney
at one point made more money than the
stores made
and so it's a you know it's a change in
in the way
debt has been marketed so aggressively
that it's become the norm and this idea
that
a
newer car
with a payment is less dangerous than a
payment right that's uh that's an
interesting
shift that has occurred but
you know if you're the parent of a
college student you're younger than me
because my kids are all older than that
so there you go or you could be likely
younger than me